And it's a great segue from collective
behavior in surprise minimizing agents
to collective behavior in surprise
minimizing agents, I guess. Welcome,
Connor. Hey. Sorry, I just turned on my
audio, so I just heard the last thing
you said. Yeah. Hey, welcome. Yes,
thanks. Um, we're looking forward to
your presentation. Multi agent active
inference and multiscale alignment,
current developments and challenges. So
feel free to share your screen or
proceed however you prefer. Great,
thanks. And before I start, because I've
had issues with my voice saturating,
like my microphone saturating, how's my
audio? Is it clipping at all? Or does
this sound okay? This is good and I'm
watching it. Okay, perfect. Thank you.
I will share my screen.
Share this one. The one thing I'll note
oh, yes. OK. It's just JF symbolic
implementation does not use statistical
distributions. It uses the symbolic
and the logical inference. And now we're
going to move back into the
distributional space, and it will be
awesome to see similarities and
differences. So thank you, Connor, to
you for the presentation.
And thank you, Daniel, for the
introduction and for inviting me, as
well as big thank you to the other
organizers of the Third Applied Active
Influence Symposium. Yeah, I'm really
happy to be here to present. So. My name
is Connor Hines. I'm a PhD student at
the Max Planck Institute of Animal
Behavior. And I'm also a researcher at
the Versus AI research lab.
R D lab. So I'm going to do something a
little bit, I guess, unconventional for
people in my position. Like, I'm a
junior researcher coming to the end of
my PhD. So usually when I give a talk,
I would present on my own research,
like what I've been up to for the last
ten years working on. But instead of
that, I'm actually going to talk about
given the motivation of the symposium,
I'm going to talk about something that's
more of an overview or perspective on
the current state of the field in
multiscale active inference or multi
agent active inference and what, in my
opinion, we need to do to move forward
as a field. I think that's very resonant
with the kind of motivations and the
title, indeed, of this symposium. So I'm
going to give a general analysis of what
multiscale active inference is, why it's
important. I'm going to provide a brief
analysis of its formal basis as it
currently stands, and then what we need
to develop in this kind of subdiscipline
of active inference, multiscale active
inference, to really make it rigorous
and really to actually reap the benefits
of what it promises.
So generally, active inference has been
used a lot to design agents that can
solve problems, plan, and just generally
emulate behavior that we deem
intelligent, which includes things like
risk sensitive decision making,
intrinsic motivations to resolve
uncertainty, and finally, from a more
scientific standpoint, the ability to
furnish a process theory about how
biological brains actually might work.
But in a lot of the theoretical work on
active inference from the last ten years
or ten plus years, really, there's also
alongside all the kind of practical
building adaptive agents, there's a
claim that active inference is
inherently or intrinsically multiscale
from the very get go. It is a multiscale
framework. It's not just about building
single agents. So it's really whenever
we write down a single active inference
agent, what we're implicitly implying is
also a nested hierarchy of active
inference agents both below and above.
So colloquially, you'll often see this
in papers as the idea that there's
Markov blankets all the way down Markov
blanket is a statistical structure
that's very kind of intrinsic to the
definition of agents as they are defined
under active inference. So I'm not going
to get into defining that. I'm kind of
assuming that there's a more
disciplinarian audience there, but I'm
sure other talks, for instance, can
provide better clarity. So yeah, Markov
blanket's active inference all the way
down, all the way up. And at any given
scale, crucially, the free energy
minimizing dynamics, or the active
inference dynamics are kind of claimed
to be aligned with or parallel to the
free energy minimizing gradients at the
level below and above. So the claim is
that as agents are doing their thing and
doing active inference at one level, it
both entails and is constrained by
active inference processes of the macro
agent that they're participating in. So
I'm a cell that's part of a tissue as
well as the micro agents that comprise
them. I am a free energy minimizing
cellular agent comprised of organelles
that are also minimizing free energy.
So this kind of constrained neat
nested gradient descent on free energy
is part of the story of multiscale
active inference. And it also crucially,
assumes that these dynamics are aligned,
correlated cooperative across these
different scales. So I should mention
that there is a formal argument made
more recently, I would say in the last
five years, about how this is possible.
And it relies on an apparatus from
statistical physics called the
Renormalization group. This basically
allows you to analytically identify
shared symmetries energy and
conservation laws at different scales in
a given system that's comprised of
subsystems and subsystems, so on
infinitum. So there's a formal argument
specifically made in a free energy
principle for a particular physics
monograph in 2019 that applies the
renormalization group apparatus to
multivariate stochastic differential
equations that are kind of the
equivalent of agents. So you can apply
that framework to certain sorts of
coupled stochastic differential
equations that exhibit Markov blanketed
sparse coupling structure. And you can
kind of prove analytically that there
are going to be nested systems of Markov
blankets and that they're all in some
sense minimizing three energies at their
own scales. So I'll get more into that
argument later, but I just want to
mention that as I define multiscale
active inference that there is a formal
argument that's related to it. So this
slide I just put together to demonstrate
the idea of nested free energy
minimizing processes visually. So at a
given scale, we can think of an agent as
occupying some point in its free energy
landscape indicated by this red orb,
which represents, say, its
configuration, its beliefs, and its
actions. And it performs active
inference and in doing so minimizes its
free energy. So it changes the position
of that ball on that landscape. And that
is all we mean when we say active
inference. That corresponds to the agent
doing inference and doing action and
kind of getting to the fixed point of
its local free energy landscape. The
multi agent case is simply when we add
more of these processes. So there's
other agents usually assumed to be
similar agents, and the word similarity,
let's put an asterisk on that. And
they're all sitting at different points
in their own free energy landscapes.
The position of their local red ball is
maybe in a different place. So the claim
of multiscale active inference is that
as we link these multiple active
inference agents together, so they can
actually exchange information like
observations and actions with each
other, what we automatically get is some
kind of superagent that is also
minimizing variation of free energy and
is in some sense an emergent or
Supervenient active inference agent.
And I say the word, we automatically get
a superagent with an asterisk because
there may be some conditions on that
mapping from local to global that have
to be elucidated. So we'll come back to
that in a bit. But in short, I think the
definition of multiscale active
inference is very eloquently put in this
paper by Rafael Kaufman,
Pranav Gupta, and Jacob Taylor. I think
Rafael Kaufman is actually going to be
on the panel later. And this line from
their paper is a really nice, I think,
just summary of what it is. So I'll just
read it out loud. The upshot is that in
theory, any active inference agent at
one Spaciotemporal scale could be
simultaneously composed of nested active
inference agents at the scale below and
constituent of a larger active inference
agent at the scale above it. In effect,
active inference allows you to pick a
composite system or agent A that you
want to understand. And it will be
generally true that both that agent A is
an approximate global minimizer of free
energy at the scale at which that agent
reliably persists, and that agent A is
composed of subsystems A, sub I that
are approximate local minimizers with
free energy. So that is the claim as I'm
going to continue evaluating
in this talk, and I think it's just a
great reference point to make,
okay, that's what multiscale active
inference is. Why is it important? Why
do we actually care about that? That
sounds philosophically nice and
beautiful visually, but why is that
important? So there's a ton of actually
really important implications of this,
both for the engineering and the natural
sciences. First of all, the namesake of
this symposium, I assume inspired by
this recent paper by Karl Frison and all
about enacting ecosystems of
parenthetically shared intelligence. So
this is the third applied active
inference symposium. So to really make
this resonate with the applied aspect,
let's make this very concrete. If we can
figure out this multiscale endeavor,
then we can actually engineer
distributed systems of multiaging
intelligence where local agents, in
doing their own little local active
inference processes, are also
cooperatively instantiating a global
agent that's also performing active
inference. This has huge computational
potential, of course, compared to kind
of the state of the art predominant
methods for artificial intelligence,
which are deep learning, which really is
about propagating global information
through an entire computation graph. So
although you could argue back
propagation is local in some sense,
it's really not local in the way that
multiscale active inference progresses
to be local. So if we can figure out how
to actually engineer multiscale active
inference, it will have really
tremendous implications for the study of
artificial intelligence just from that
pure engineering standpoint. It'll be
cheaper. In one word, it'll be
computationally energetically, memory
wise. Cheaper. A lot cheaper.
Secondly, from a kind of more natural
sciences motivation, which is kind of
where I'm coming from, I'm doing a PhD
in biology, so I'm interested in
questions about actual real systems in
nature. Just the idea of being able to
get super specific and rigorous about
phrases like emergent intelligence,
emergent computation, collective
intelligence, superorganism that's often
thrown around. We're talking about
social insects, right? These are terms
that you hear thrown around in many
different scientific disciplines that
deal with multi agent systems, network
systems. But none of these terms, to my
knowledge, have really rigorous or
precise conditions. Multiscale active
inference is a kind of framework that's
in the position to provide those
rigorous definitions and conditions. So
from a scientific standpoint, it could
really lend a lot of potential and
usefulness for other scientific
disciplines. And finally, another
pragmatic motivation. There's loads of
fields that are obsessed with designing
and engineering systems where local,
selfish individual behavior can
lead when networked appropriately to
some desired collective outcome. And
these disciplines really want to figure
out how to engineer that properly. So
this goes from the design of financial
markets and trading systems all the way
down to how do you design a multiplayer
video game? So that's kind of just
motivating. Why is multiscale active
inference even interesting? So then the
question, of course, becomes, is the
multiscale active inference claim
actually true? Are all multi agent
active inference systems comprised of
and themselves comprise nested hierarchy
of free energy minimization agents? A
glance at a smattering of other
scientific disciplines that specifically
deal with multiple agents, multiple
interests, collective phenomena like
coordination, group behavior,
collective intelligence. A glance at all
those disciplines would naively suggest
that the answer is no. So there's things
like frustration in thermodynamic
systems game theory, the very existence
of zero sum games and mass equilibria
bandwagon effects when we're talking
about social networks and opinion
dynamics. Sacrifices for the common
good, which we see in different contexts
in biology, like in the context of kin
selection, but also in the context of
arguably cell death in a tissue.
These are all basically plenty of
systems where local constraints and
global constraints or desires or free
energy gradients, whatever you want to
call them, come into direct conflict.
So the obvious example that I listed at
the top of these bullets is the idea of
geometric frustration that we see in
Icing systems with very low temperature.
So these Icing models basically describe
lattices of Ferromagnets that are happy
when they're pointing in the same
direction as their neighboring
Ferromagnets and they can be in an up or
a down state. So basically the magnet
can be pointing up or pointing down.
And these global systems are defined by
a global energy function and the whole
system is in some sense trying to
minimize that global energy function.
But sometimes you'll find cases in these
collective systems where this little
spin in the middle cannot be happy
because they're getting conflicting
information from two neighbors. I want
to be pointing up in blue like the agent
on the left, but I also want to be
pointing down like the agent on the
right. So this is a system that's
collectively finding some fixed point of
its global free energy, but it's
actually leading to a local conflict
where this agent is not at a point where
it can do anything to make itself happy
or minimize its free energy further. So
just from even the basic glance at
Ferromagnetic lattices, we already see
instances where local and global
gradients or local and global optima are
not aligned in the right way. So given
all this, the burden of proof for
multiscale active inference is still on
us. So we need to show that collective
active inference systems generically do
align again across scales. And maybe if
we can put an X across the word
generically and it's not some automatic
condition, if they don't, then at least
we have to establish exactly the
conditions in which they do. So
anecdotally we do actually have some
conditions. There seem to be some kind
of basic ingredients to get collective
active inference to work. So one is that
we basically need agents to exchange
actions and sensations across some kind
of Markov blanket. This is not really a
condition. This is almost more part of
what it means to be an agent. So having
Markov blanket separation between agents
is just another way of saying we have
multiple agents in our system rather
than a single agent if you're violating
the Markov blanket property. So internal
states of one agent are not allowed to
see the internal states or external
states of another agent. Then you're
kind of cheating because you're kind of
saying it's actually one agent. And what
you're doing is information sharing
within the brain of a single agent. The
second condition, which is something
that's often hallucinated more
anecdotally and not really formally, is
this idea that agents need to have some
kind of shared narrative or shared
hidden states or censor space in their
generative model. So I've worked a lot
on collective active inference systems,
just simulating agents and trying to get
them to do interesting things together.
And my intuitions and experience do
agree with this basic fact. If the
agents don't have any similarity in what
they're representing or trying to
achieve, then it's kind of like trying
to fit a square peg into a circular
hole. So this is really nicely
elucidated in one of the earliest cases
in this paper, a Duet for One by first
and Fritz in 2015, where they show that
for two agents to really align, they
kind of have to have a shared generative
model and then you can get kind of this
nice synchronized behavior. Again,
though, these things like what does
similarity mean? What does a shared
narrative actually mean? Formally,
mathematically, those things have not
been initiated yet. So right now, a lot
of the building of these collective
systems is based on our intuitions and
kind of engineering things using some
vague guidelines like, oh, they should
have a shared sensor space, but there's
no mathematical conditions or guarantees
about what degree of similarity is
needed between two agents models to get
the intended dynamics. And finally, we
have to have at least some agreement
between the generative model of each
agent and the generative process, which
is really the behavior of the other
agents generating their data. So this is
kind of related to the previous point
about having shared generative models.
But just to be very specific, the
physics of the space that transfers your
actions to my observations that physics
can't be dramatically crazily different
than how our generative models represent
those physics. So if we took two fish
with the same generative model of each
other and they normally would school
together in a fish tank, but we throw
them in a volcano or shoot them out into
outer space they won't. School together.
Because then the generative process is
so dramatically deviating from the way
they are representing that physics, the
way their generative model is
constructed. So these are, again just
ingredients, kind of guidelines or
anecdotes. But there's nothing really
rigorous behind these conditions.
They're more like a list of best
practices. So now let's get on to actual
rigorous stuff. So, the first real
rigorous attempt to show that multiscale
active inference generally works is in
one section of this free energy
principle for a particular physics
monograph from 2019. So it leverages
this apparatus I mentioned earlier, the
Renormalization group operator, to
basically show how one can successively
coarse grain multivariate stochastic
differential equations that admit sparse
coupling between their state variables.
So the main result in my mind that
connects these renormalization group
results to multiscale active inference
is the fact that the Lagrangian of the
system at one scale can be expressed as
a function of the Lagrangian at other
scales. And that applies in a scale
invariant fashion that is the main kind
of output or the main benefit of using a
renormalization group apparatus. So you
can kind of think of Lagrangian like the
generative model. It's a physics term,
but it's related to the generative model
of the agents that comprise the system
and therefore also their free energy.
So in terms of active inference, it
means that this reasoning of the
renormalization group can be used to
smoothly move between the models of
individual agents at one scale and the
model of a collective or larger agent at
a different scale or a smaller scale for
that matter. And the nice thing about it
is general for all kinds of dynamics and
thus generative models, it doesn't
depend heavily on the form of the
stochastic differential equations that
form your system. The issues
with it is that there's not a global
link to Bayesian mechanics and active
inference. It's still all done in the
traditional physics formalism. So we
don't actually have an explicit link to
local inference and global inference.
Although if you know the connection
between the Lagrangian and the
generative model and the free energy,
then you can make that connection. But
it's not actually made explicitly for us
in this part of the monograph. It also
requires the assumption that the
generative model and the generative
process are identical at the local level
that's related to how the Lagrangian is
defined. That's also restrictive
assumption. That's probably not
realistic in my opinion. And then
finally, there's something about kind of
spatiotemporal segregation of scales.
So we need to make assumptions about how
fast random fluctuations are at one
scale relative to another scale in order
to justify kind of coarse grading or
forgetting about certain states as you
move between scales. And that's also
something that you could argue. Current
research into collective dynamics
challenges that assumption about how
fast noise is at one scale relative to
the next. So now I'm going to discuss
quickly another small contingent of
active inference research that is
attempted to address this mapping
between local and global inference
processes. So what I want to kind of
just generally say with this
presentation and to our community is
that the kind of approach taken in these
two papers, first of all, active
inference model of collective
intelligence and spin glass systems as
collective active inference. This is one
of the types of research I think we
really need to move active inference,
multiscale active inference forward. So
I'm not trying to be too biased because
I am the first author on the second of
those papers, but I'll also be the first
one to point out the limitation. But
benefits wise, I think these approaches
are really important because they
formally relate a local generative model
at one scale to a global generative
model at a different scale. So really
tie, how do the parameters of one model
relate to a course grade model? And
these are really good steps in the
direction of a formal theory of
collective intelligence that goes from
local intelligences to global
intelligence. However, there's still
issues with these. One of them is that
they only deal with issue with inference
at the global level, not active
inference. So both these papers concern
with a bunch of local active inference
agents that cooperate to form a global
inference agent, like a passive baying
agent, rather than an active inference
agent. And it's also unclear whether the
systems studying these papers are
actually very generic. Like the results
are generic to studying collective
intelligence in general, or they're nice
formal arguments, but they're only
applicable to these specific systems.
So we still don't have something that's
even more kind of zoomed out and
abstract than these, which tend to be a
little bit case specific. And finally,
the actual scale transcendence that
we're doing in these papers is still
relegated to really one step. We're not
doing the full multiscale infinite
scale regression that something like
Renormalization group promises. So
that's kind of the current overview of
what I think are the most promising
directions in multiscale active
inference. And I'm aware on time,
sorry, five minutes. So I'm going to
quickly try to go through what I think
are really promising directions to push
in terms of multiscale active inference
and kind of intuition pumps that I think
will help us study these systems
in a way that's different and also
actually better informed by other
research disciplines. So the general
idea that I'd like to put forward is
that misaligned gradients can actually
be a good thing. So it's actually
sometimes good when local free energy
gradients are misaligned with global
gradients. So sometimes the global
system will actually do better if the
local systems are performing worse. So
this is something you could call
multiscale conflict, where the free
energy minimizing processes at one scale
are actually doing bad, quote unquote,
but it's because they're being driven by
some higher scale process that is doing
well. So rather than trying to always
avoid constructing processes like this,
I think this kind of frustration, to use
the analogy from statistical physics,
can actually be an inspiration for what
we should investigate further because it
actually might be key to facilitating
optimality at different scales.
The reason I put this forward is because
there's loads of research, just recent
research in the last several years that
are suggesting that actually making
local agents more frustrated or more
unhappy might coincidentally or not
coincidentally lead to better collective
or global outcomes. So this is expressed
in various forms in various bodies of
work. One of the biggest patterns I've
noticed is the study of collective
behavioral systems over the last several
decades is the idea that local noise and
local Dysregulation can often facilitate
global coherence or global coordination.
And where multiscale active inference
has something to say, in my opinion, is
in framing this benefit of local
frustration in terms of a misalignment
of free energy gradients. So it may be
that actually temporary misalignment
local free energy gradients from global
ones may facilitate the descent to fix
points in the global free energy
landscape that satisfy everyone at all
scales. So I'm basically expressing an
idea that's been known in various
communities like Stochastic optimization
and Stochastic resonance theory for
decades. But I think we as active
inference practitioners have a new and
potentially useful perspective to shed
on that, using the language of active
inference and free energy minimization
and Bayesian inference in general. So
instead of thinking of accelerating
optimization by just adding noise to the
system, we can think of exactly how to
design local generative models such that
there's an optimal misalignment of local
and global gradients or local and global
generative models in a way that
facilitates everyone in the long run
actually facilitating or minimizing
their free energy. So yeah,
that's just kind of like something I'm
putting out there. I'm investigating it
now in my own work, but I have no real
results on that. But I just wanted to
put that out there in this venue because
I think it maybe will inspire other
people to think in a similar way. So
just to conclude, now, multiscale active
inference, I would say, is still largely
based on theoretical or philosophical
descriptions and illustrious
simulations, but we're still lacking a
formal theory. There's some theory in
terms of the renormalization group
arguments of the monograph, but they're
still, in my opinion, a bit
underdeveloped, a little under
demonstrated and relying on some
restrictive assumptions like the fast
and slow fluctuations, the identity
between generative model, generative
process. There's a few more recent
papers, those two by Kaufman at all and
then by myself on spingglass systems
that have attempted particular proofs of
multi scale Bayesian inference systems
in particular situations, but their
generality is still not known and not
proven. So what I'm kind of trying to
conclude with is by saying we need to
incorporate findings from other
disciplines related to the role of
noise, conflict and frustration in
facilitating, not subverting collective
intelligence or collective coordination.
And I think we can really benefit by
looking at these other disciplines to
help us build a really powerful formal
theory of multiscale active inference.
And finally, I think we need to set the
goalpost for what counts as a formal
proof of multiscale active inference.
And once we get there, once we're
saying, okay, this counts as proof,
this is satisfying, how can we use that
to actually do the hardest part, in my
opinion, which is engineering actual
multiscale active inference systems that
are intelligent and minimizing free
energy at multiple scales. Yeah,
so with that, I'm going to conclude
looks like I'm just on time. So, yeah,
thank you again for the invitation to
present, and I'd like to thank a bunch
of people who are listed here and beyond
who have influenced my thinking and kind
of my opinions. If there's time, I'm
happy to take any questions.
Awesome. Great talk.
I'll just give a few seconds if anybody
wants to type in a question. Also, it's
really cool. Like, aswin in the previous
session was highlighting Pymdp and just
the way in which we
enact the collective intelligence.
Different people seeing a paper where an
analytical formalization is introduced,
and then there's still so much work to
get it to the package, and then so much
more work to take it to the last mile.
And I think your presentation really
checked a lot of those boxes. I'll just
read a question and then that will just
be an appetizer for our continued
discussion. So Marco Lynn asked,
do you expect the inferentially
connected dynamics to exhibit behavior
akin to theories of multi body systems?
And to what extent can we transfer
insights from that multi body of work?
And then second question, just for our
thinking and learning from Marco, have
you explored integrating work on
self organized criticality with multi
scale active inference or other
frameworks? Who can provide more
flexible frameworks or assumptions for a
generic notion of multiscale dynamics?
Great questions. I hope that we can
continue, have you back anytime, or just
continue to collaborate in the
ecosystem. So thank you for the epic
talk, Connor, and good luck finishing
your PhD. Thanks a lot, Daniel. Yeah,
I'll talk to you soon. Talk to you soon.